speaking of vegeta you you gave dragon
ball and dragon ball z both
a nine out of ten yeah i thought dragon
ball was [ __ ]
no that's good all right i know you're
gonna look at me in the eye and say it's
a
the original dragon ball is a nine no
okay again this this puts into
perspective how long ago was that i
probably put that in
like how many [ __ ] darymon movies you
gave [ __ ] a darymon movie a
masterpiece you give that a ten and you
gonna give the
way which one which story i won the
movie
16 you gave a 10. what is special about
16. okay that wasn't like the
schindler's list of derived ones
okay that was the third doraemon movie
uh i think it's 16. no that the remake
is 16.
what the [ __ ] yeah the the original is
the third one which i couldn't find
which it doesn't exist on my anime list
for some reason all right okay but i
gave that a 10
purely because i watched that movie that
that was one of the first orion movies i
ever watched and
i mean if you guys don't know that right
i'm a bad guy now
yeah it's it's good like that honestly
like sweat like
even now i could probably watch that
movie and still find it enjoyable
yeah i don't know durian diamond holds a
special place in my heart as you can
tell from the amount of [ __ ] door i'm
on movies
yeah yeah i'm just like i didn't even
know there were this many dare i want me
to do they're still making dorado i'm
i'm surprised someone else has been
watching durham on
like further along than when they were a
kid watching on tv because that's the
only
exposure i've ever had yeah right i
probably would never go out my way
yeah too much of [ __ ] i completely
understand if you did not grow up with
diamond
i do not blame you for not watching a
single diamond movie or episode because
that shit's hard to get into as an adult
but if you grew up with it like i did
then you could easily go back
i know man to me it's kind of like yeah
as a growing up grand assad i'll just
like watch the [ __ ] teletubbies movie
yeah right right
like or it's like door of the explorer
yeah yeah you have to like talk to like
a niece or something and then you're
like oh show me what you watch and you
watch it you're like what the [ __ ] is
happening
this is [ __ ] it's just wild what is this
that's probably what my parents thought
when i was watching what the [ __ ] is
this blue thing
i i noticed you gave full metal
alchemist and full metal alchemist
brotherhood both are seven
yeah why because it's like my hero it
was no
it wasn't just being a brotherhood is
not it's like at least an
eight or a nine it was except i mean
okay look acceptable yeah it was
acceptable hold on hold on
let me let me let me act uh let me act
angry okay
wait you gave full metal alchemist at
seven how
dare you joey how dare you i am so
[ __ ] offended right now
it is the audacity of this [ __ ] man the
audacity
to the new viewers gone has never won
that scene with
nina and the dog mike did did you not
get the feels from that i'm not i love
that that's the first thing you think of
i'm not trying to say like you need to
give it like a 10. i'm just saying
i think it's like minimum okay okay
here's the thing with that one i still
stand by that to this day because
like a lot of people it was not the
first anime i watched i watched that
right
way after a kid yeah me too right right
yeah but it was probably one of the
first ones you watched right
for the first 20 yeah exactly what does
that count this might have been in like
the first 200 for me
but i don't know i feel like out of all
the anime i've watched definitely the
best here's the thing
my my experience with fullmetal
alchemist is basically gone's next step
which is
because i hear about it so much i
watched it out of obligation
god hasn't gone to the stage i haven't
got to that stage
every time someone asks me a day gets
added on exactly i'm pretty sure
like and i was like and i was like that
as well and i'm just like you know what
i got time i'll [ __ ] watch it just
because i know both of them are in the
same
like sitting or what like i have no i
watched so so i watched
so people were like okay you don't have
to watch the first four
that all the [ __ ] time but i'm like
no no i want to see why people are
saying that
right so i watched the original and i
was like okay
this was adequate so brotherhood must be
a lot better like a lot lot better
that's what i heard yeah i think and i
was like yeah it's better but
like essentially this serves a point
higher better it's essentially no
it's not okay the first full metal
alchemist is like a low seven
and brotherhood is like a high seven car
it is that's all it is to me